we need to keep the momentum going for
the we want Stargate campaign and I've
got an idea a slightly old-school way of
doing it welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
[Music]
so yeah we use Twitter we had the
Twitter storm hashtag we want Stargate
and we've shouted as loud as we could
that we desperately want our favorite
show to return I do constant videos
talking about how much we desperately
want Stargate to return because it's my
favorite show now even though I'm very
worried about what they might do with
this franchise when it does return I
desperately want to see new Stargate on
our screens
but we need to keep the momentum going
because there has been still no official
announcement from Amazon about what
they've planned to do with it it does
look like that Brad Wright isn't going
to be involved it does look like we're
going to hear something by January 15th
when epics becomes MGM plus I am told
that there has been several marketing
meetings where they're hoping to get a
final decision on Stargate by that date
so they can use it to really advertise
the new MGM plus streaming Network
but
it's not in the bag yet no final
decision has been made and that final
decision the man that we need to really
convince the Stargate must return has a
name
his name is Michael Wright
now Michael Wright is not just the
president of epics he's also the
president of all of MGM scripted
material so everything that has a script
basically everything that's not you know
sports or you know reality TV or news or
whatever everything that has this
scripted content is all signed off by
Michael Wright he's the man whose
signature we need on that contract to
get this show going so we had an idea an
actual subscriber came to me when you
know what what if we wrote physical
letters to somebody who would we write
them to
we write them to Michael Wright so
send letters polite letters nice letters
saying pretty please will you
please bring back our favorite TV show
send them care of Michael Wright to the
address below
now this is mgm's headquarters he has
offices there in California and Beverly
Hills he has an office in this building
so let's send him a lovely letter now
one of my level subscribers on a
suggesting the Community page says
they'll send him hate mail or a dead
squirrel don't do that send him lovely
letters because we want to sweet talking
but send letters now I am going to write
mine today and I'm going to send it
tomorrow morning by airmail
I ask all of you please do the same
let's actually not just do the Twitter
storm something they can ignore let's
actually fill their letterbox full of
letters with Stargate on let's actually
do something real something they can
hold in their hands something that
actually shows an element of effort
required because at the end of the day
anybody can write hashtag we want
Stargate takes two seconds it's a
throwaway thing to do it takes time to
write a letter to put a stamp on it to
put in an envelope and send it it
actually costs a little bit of money
even a few hundred letters through their
door would I think have much more of an
impact than any Twitter storm
so let's do it let's go old school
get your pen and paper out and write a
letter a lovely letter to Mr Michael
Wright president MGM
God I hope this one works this would be
amazing if this actually made a
difference I think it's such a simple
idea so hey let's do it and again no
hate letters do not write don't make it
woke or anything like that in there just
write a lovely letter please begging for
the new TV show say look we know you're
thinking about it we know you've even
done some planning please pull the
trigger and do it so get in the comments
guys tell us when you've written your
letter tell us if you've got any other
ideas about how we can bring back
Stargate because I want to hear them and
if there are good ideas like this one
then I will make a video and I will push
for it so let's do it guys let's get
some real momentum and let's push
forwards until January and make sure
they make the right decision if you are
new to the Channel please like subscribe
hit that Bell notification really helps
us out also if you enjoy the content you
can hit the join button because that
really supports the channel as always
please stay safe write your letters and
I'll see you soon
[Music]